Stand on the blue line right behind you.
Take one step forward…
Perfect.
That’s great.
Brexit is very likely to have a big adverse
economic and political effect on the United
Kingdom
that would more than offset any long term
gains that they might get from exiting the
union.
This is because Brexit would almost certainly
promote a Sterling crisis, since there'd be
a lot of uncertainty in the two years that
Britain would be renegotiating terms with
Europe
and that British financial institutions would
be losing their financial passport, and locating
in Europe.
The second reason that it would be bad for
the United Kingdom is that it would very likely
result in a second Scottish referendum on
independence.
Scotland doesn't want to be part of the United
Kingdom, rather wants to part of Europe
and that could lead to the dissolution of
the United Kingdom in its present state.
And that would be another factor contributing
to economic and political uncertainty.
My view is that Brexit is a bad idea.
Please let us know your view in your comments,
and what other topics you'd like us to discuss
in 60 seconds.